well it was a it was a good good time at
Baylor last night great turnout
respectful audience no outbursts or
anything of that sort a peaceful
peaceful that there that could be
because the university from from what I
was told they counter program the event
they were holding something called a it
was a love dinner or a love feast
something like that
and which again from what I was told was
was advertised as a an alternative to my
speech so I think the idea was to try to
siphon people away from what I was doing
but we still packed the house and and it
was great the only the only little
strange thing was that it was you know
it's pretty hot down here in Waco right
and so you can imagine if he'd pack
hundreds of people into a little room it
gets even hotter well the the AC wasn't
running during my talk so we were all
just sweating pouring sweat and then
strangely enough as soon as the talk
ended the AC kicked on and so kind of
weird I mean and maybe just a
coincidence I don't know but a little
strange I want to get into conspiracy
theories but who knows anyway my next
stop will be the the standing up for
faith and freedom conference at what AF
headquarters in Reston Virginia and then
I'll be at embry-riddle university in
Daytona Beach on April 16th so I hope to
see you there now hopefully there'll be
some AC crank in there in Daytona Beach
though now some bunch of things talk
about let's start with this some news
from Bernie Sanders very very exciting
news from him the lifetime avowed
socialist announced yesterday that he is
a millionaire so congratulations to
Bernie Sanders on that if you got
something a pretty exciting stuff he's
planning to finally release his taxes
you know you know how much grief he gave
Donald Trump over never releasing his
taxes well Sanders has yet to release
his own but he says he's going to do
that in the next few days but just to
sort of pave the way and
and let us know ahead of time he said
that he is a millionaire he's not a
billionaire though he doesn't have he
said he doesn't have investments in
Saudi Arabia he's not a billionaire but
he is a millionaire
this was his exact quote he said I wrote
a best-selling book if you write a
best-selling book you can be a
millionaire - that sounds like the title
a book if you write a you know if you
write a best-selling book you could be a
millionaire - well what a what a change
in messaging that is right for Bernie
Sanders from from ranting about the the
evil millionaires and billionaires to
now saying you can be a millionaire -
that's it's very different it's very
it's a that's quite a change from
millionaires and billionaires are evil -
now he's giving tips he's giving
financial tips on how to become one but
of course the whole point here is that
his preferred policies if his preferred
policies were in place if his socialist
policies were in place if we were a
socialist nation then you you could not
become a millionaire by writing a
best-selling book you wouldn't have that
option so this is something that he was
able to do because we live in a
capitalist country he capitalized on the
fact that we are a capitalist nation and
seemed to have no problem doing that
yet he still claims to be a socialist so
it's just like aoc saying hey airplanes
commercial air travels destroying the
country just destroying the world and
we're all gonna be dead in 12 years yet
she has no problem getting on getting on
planes and jet-setting around around the
country now I don't personally begrudge
anyone you going on an airplane or
becoming a millionaire I you know I
think it's great that people are able to
do that in this country I think it's
great that people are able to become
millionaires I think it's great that
you're able to become a millionaire not
just by writing a book but by writing a
bad book and like the one that Bernie
Sanders wrote I think it's it's it's
it's amazing that it's that easy like
you don't even have to be good at
anything you can still become a
millionaire what exact like
Bernie Sanders what exactly is his what
is he good at what's his what's his
thing what is his skill what's his
talent I'm not sure that he has won but
he was still able to become a
millionaire because of our free market
system I think that's great you know as
a as a capitalist myself but Bernie
Sanders is not a capitalism so I would
think that this would have to destroy
his campaign right I mean I don't see
how he survives it and it's pretty sad
when the fact that you're financially
successful is some sort of scandal that
that can can harm you politically but it
shouldn't be that way and for most
politicians it wouldn't be but that's
the situation that he's set up for
himself
he's the one who's who's been going
around decrying wealth and he's gonna
have to face the music someone said to
me yesterday I made this point and
someone said well you know how can you
criticize Bernie Sanders for for being a
millionaire when Donald Trump is a
billionaire and you're not critical of
that yeah except that Donald Trump
wasn't going around and saying that
there's anything wrong with being
wealthy quite the opposite actually
so if you're a capitalist and you're and
you're open and proud of it then fine be
as rich as you want but if you're a
socialist you can't go getting rich on
us can you so I think this is gonna hurt
him but at least Bernie can go home and
console himself by rolling around in a
huge pile of money okay let's take a
look at this real quick
our friend Johan Omar was speaking to a
Muslim rights group and she
characterized 9/11 in kind of a bizarre
way and a troubling way watch this here
was founded after 9/11 because they
recognized that some people did
something and that all of us were
starting to lose access to our civil
liberties some people did something
that's how she category
is 911 some people did something that's
pretty incredible that this woman is
just so consistently vile it's almost
impressive and I'll tell you this if I
were a Muslim I would not be a fan of
Ilhan Omar at all because she seems
determined to fulfill every negative
Muslim stereotype she possibly can
she's constantly she's constantly
complaining about Jews now she's
downplaying 9/11 I mean every stereotype
she can think of she tries to affirm
this is this is really incredible this
is a this is you know this is not just
some cable news pundit or something this
is a sitting member of Congress who says
of 9/11 some people did something that
is a horrifying all right a woman by the
name of Ariel Haspel Haspel a spell will
just say hospital is under fire today
she's under fire because she committed
the sin of get ready for this and
because she did something pretty
horrifying here's what she did this
woman she she opened a Chinese
restaurant and the restaurant is called
Lucky Li's and this is a sin because as
I'm sure you've guessed it Ariel is
white gasp and she sinned further by
endeavoring to make clean and healthy
Chinese food she said in a post online
that she that a lot of American Chinese
food is unhealthy according to her and
she said it makes you feel quote bloated
and icky and so she wanted to make make
food that that doesn't have that effect
now as someone who has you know myself
eaten probably eight or nine tons of
Chinese food in my life or even just in
the past save two months I can confirm
that yes bloated and icky is probably a
pretty accurate description of how you
often feel after indulging in some you
know General Tso's chicken or Kung Pao
from your local Chinese place that
doesn't stop me of course I still eat it
but I
I think that this is sort of undeniable
that the American Chinese food has that
effect I can't speak to you know
authentic Chinese food in China I've
never had it but that's the case with
American Chinese food yet it's all it is
it is very racist apparently for this
person to say that and the fact that
she's the fact that she's white inmate
in opening this Chinese restaurant the
first place is racist the name of the
establishment lucky Lee's his racist the
fact that you accused other Chinese food
of being unhealthy is racist all of that
is racist so a bunch of leftist decided
to get together and of course destroy
this woman's business because hey why
not look let's just try to tear down
this woman and her business and she's
been working for you know to to open
your own business takes a lot of time
and effort in capital I'm sure this is a
dream she's had for a long time and she
finally gets the place open she's so
excited and but these people are saying
you know what let's just let's just
let's just tear it apart you know it's
just we'll just destroy it because
because hey we got nothing better to do
ruin her livelihood you know because
because we're vile
ridiculous idiots so the backlash seems
to have started with let me see if I
could pull up there were a couple of
tweets that seemed have started this
whole thing one from Lana Olmstead who
said who tweeted a picture of
Arial and said wow wow wow this white
woman pictured just opened a clean
Chinese food restaurant in NYC called
lucky Lee's not only is she using
Chinese food stereotypes slash naming
she is shaming traditional Chinese food
cooking with MSG grease and starch and
then one of the other early tweets came
from someone named McKenzie says oh I
can not with Lucky Lee's this new clean
Chinese restaurant that some white
Wellness blogger just opened in New York
her blog talks about how Chinese food is
usually doused in brown sauces and makes
your eyes puffy lady what and just a lot
of a lot of stuff like that a lot of
people who who simply cannot they just
cannot well you know what if you cannot
then then leave the woman a lot you
don't have to go to the restaurant if
you don't like it
right and again is she wrong about what
she's saying
American Chinese food is doused in brown
sauces it is I mean I don't know if it
makes my eyes puffy but what are we now
pretending that it's that it's healthy
or something like that and then from
there a bunch of morons flooded her Yelp
page posted negative reviews of her
restaurant even though these people had
course never actually been to the
restaurant so they were just lying and
then other websites jumped on the dog
pile the site eater calm a food site
posted an article with a headline
claiming in the headline that the
restaurant is is drawing quote swift
backlash for quote racist language that
it used that was in the headline it
wasn't it wasn't didn't say alleged
racist language or some people claimed
right no just racist language well what
racist language where is the racist
language you're telling me that if you
if you describe Chinese food in a
negative way that that's racist racist
to the food who you being racist against
accusing a certain kind of fast food of
being unhealthy is not racist is it
racist if I say that Taco Bell
oftentimes causes diarrhea well it does
we all know that do we have to pretend
now that taco beso it says anti-hispanic
if we if we don't you know if we if we
point out the some of the side effects
of eating Taco Bell this is just so
excessively stupid and not just stupid
but but so callous and cruel and
capricious arbitrarily trying to ruin
this woman's life for no reason she
didn't do anything wrong she just opened
a restaurant and and that's all she did
and by the way people are complaining
that the name lucky leaves is racist
because Lee is a typical Chinese name
well the woman's husband who is also the
chef
his name is Lee so the rest so I guess
his parents are racist for calling him
Lee oh man
this kind of thing it it makes me so
angry because you're going after some
random person it's not like you're
attacking a public figure okay it's not
like you're for the nine millionth time
taking Donald Trump out of context and
accusing him of racism well he's the
president he can take it but it's just
some it's just a person who's excited to
open it just wasn't any conspiracy to
try to you know to try to be racist
against Chinese people this was she just
wanted to open a restaurant that's all
and and for all the talk that we hear
from liberals about hey you know live
and let live and and let people live
their own lives well as we've seen time
and time again they certainly will not
take their own advice on that score and
you know what there is of course a huge
double standard here because we all know
that if Arielle was herself let's say an
Asian woman opening a pizza restaurant
and and the pizza restaurants name was
was lucky lose or something like that
well nobody would criticize what would
she be getting would an Asian person who
opened a pizza restaurant get in trouble
for appropriating Italian culture no
that would never happen what was you
know an Indian person opening a burger
joint get in trouble for you know
appropriating Americana or whatever no
opening a barbecue joint no that would
never ever happen you would never see
that happening so if you are anything if
you're anything but white you can open
any kind of restaurant you want any kind
of food you want and people in fact if
you're you know if you if you are
non-white opening an Italian restaurant
people would be thrilled they would say
oh this is great it's a you know
diversity and everything but if you're
white no you're not allowed to you're
not allowed to open restaurants of you
know typically ethnic food it's it's
simply absurd and food
is one of those things that cultures
share and it changes and people have
their own take on it and everything
alright I just got to move on from that
but if you by the way if you if you
happen to be in New York why don't you
go by luckily z-- and and give them your
support I hope that this
I hope this woman makes you know ten
million dollars this year just just out
of spite for these idiots
all right let's check in with slate
slate always has intellectually engaging
content of course and yesterday in
slates advice column section a woman
wrote in with an interesting question
and I'm going to see if I can pull this
up here I'm gonna read the question that
she wrote the slate I just think this is
this is very it's a very revealing kind
of question and and the answer is to so
this is the question to slate it says
I'm a single woman in the early 30s I'm
attractive and have never had issues
attracting a partner but after a series
of disappointing relationships each
around a year I'm just not in the mood
to engage emotionally with men right now
the thing is I have a high sex drive and
I can't fully satisfy myself on my own
the cliche is that this should be an
easy problem to fix plenty of men want
to have sex with a woman with no strings
right well here are my limitations in
the past when I've had hookup buddies I
liked them but it never really is just
sex we inevitably get to know each other
better and then I end up getting
entangled with him whether I want to or
not I also am not really into sex
parties or the poly scene so I'm not
really sure how to proceed I've
identified a few bars in my town that
are good for this sort of thing but that
is hit or miss for finding an attractive
guy when I tell my gay friends about
this they talk about how easy it is to
find what they want on Grindr and the
like and I'm honestly jealous tinder and
similar apps for straight people are
full of creeps who have no game and I'm
afraid if I'm upfront about what I want
I'll attract even more of that type
what's a straight girl who just wants
good unattached sex to do so the
this is a woman who wants to find a good
guy a non creep that's what she's
looking for
she wants a non creep a good guy decent
guy who has game two whatever that means
but she just just for sex is just so
she's looking for a good guy he'll just
use her for sex
and then and then comes the the response
from slate it says it's true even when
both parties are completely uninterested
in anything serious or romantic
you can still eventually end up in the
bath products aisle together debating
whether your connection means anything
and having moments of odd sticky
feelings towards each other in your case
it sounds like at least some of the
entanglement is coming from your end
so put reminders in your phone make the
guys have names like Chris nothing
serious Johnson or Joe this is just sex
bTW whatever will underscore the
boundaries you've set and need to
respect for yourself in addition to
expecting the other guys to adhere to
hopefully that'll make it easier to keep
a good casual connection going without
tipping into what you don't want and
then it goes on from there okay so a
couple of observations here number one
you know if you're looking for good guys
for it for non creeps well the problem
here is gonna be that good guys aren't
looking to use women for sex that that's
it is precisely the creeps
who are going to be able to pick up at
bars who are have no emotional
attachment and it not interested
anything like that they're just looking
for sex and then they're gonna be gone
so it could be that if you want a good
man then maybe you need to be a better
person yourself see this is the advice
that I would give if she had asked me it
could be that you yourself are not a
very good person it seems like and so
that's why you attract creeps you see
you're attracting creeps because you're
a creep have you heard thought about
that you know I know that we when we
talk about people being creeps we almost
we always refer to men that ways it's
men are the only creeps well there are a
lot of men
we're creeps but then there are women
who are creeps too and based on that
based on that question you're a creep
that's just that's just weird and gross
and creepy so you're getting exactly the
kind of guy you deserve number two what
you find in the question and then in the
answer was this is so much effort right
to get around the the emotional
attachments that you naturally feel
towards someone who you're in a sexual
relationship with and so the the answer
that this person is given is well here
are some tips on on how to you know get
a get around those emotional attachment
well did it ever occur to you perhaps
that those natural that those emotional
attachments are natural because we're
human beings we're not animals and you
know maybe if you discover that you
can't help but feel some sort of
emotional attachment to the people that
you have sexual relationships with maybe
that would maybe that should tell you
something about the nature of the sexual
act that you know it's it's not just
like shaking somebody's hand it's not
just like playing video games with
somebody right it's more than a
recreational activity because you could
shake someone's hand if you'll note no
emotional attachment you can play video
games with them right you could sit and
you'd watch a movie with them you could
do all those things and feel no
emotional attachment with the sexual act
maybe there's something about it that's
different than that maybe it is a
naturally intimate and serious personal
thing and so maybe that should tell you
that the context you know there is an
appropriate context for the sexual act
and that context is not just finding
someone at a bar for one night I think
that could be the source of your problem
and I will say only as a follow-up and I
don't want to I'm not looking to rub
this into the faces of people who are
still single but when I read stuff like
this I continue to be so happy that I'm
married I am sorry I'm so happy that I'm
not on the dating scene dealing with
stuff like this and people like that it
really is so much better being married
and again if you want to get married
you're trying to and you haven't been
able to yet I'm not I'm not trying to
make you feel bad because it'll happen
you know and you if you're looking for
marriage and you're serious about you're
serious about a relationship eventually
it will happen that's the good news and
it is something look it's just it's just
so much better than this it's so much
more secure so much happier you know as
a married person out there whatever the
hell she's talking about they don't have
to worry about that all of these things
are not to worry about you don't have to
worry about creeps or anything like that
because you've got somebody you're in a
secure relationship and you know there
are challenges in a marriage but it's
I'm telling you it is so so so much
better than that is so much better I
highly recommend I couldn't recommend it
enough all right let's go check out some
emails Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt
wall show at gmail.com this is from
Simon Says hey Matt what are your
opinions on ghosts do you think they
exists does having people's do do having
people's souls stick around on earth
after death and often become malicious
make sense theologically are what people
take for ghosts just demons from our
lidget standpoint I've been on both
sides of the issue throughout my life
what do you think well Simon no I don't
think I don't believe in ghosts it
doesn't make sense theologically at all
that you would have people who died and
just hang around on earth certainly from
a biblical standpoint there's there's
there's no no precedent for that you die
and and and you're going suppli here
somewhere but you're not going to be
wandering around on earth I I do think
that sometimes you could have demonic
activity that's confused for ghostly
activity however all right this is from
who is this from Helen says hi
I've been reading your work since you
were a humble alpaca groomer it's okay
yeah thanks
it's here's my question would you
consider aborted babies to be born I've
always thought of them as being born in
the technical sense because their bodies
leave the bodies of their mothers
obvious no however it seems like I hear
both pro-life and pro-choice people
talking about aborted babies as though
they were never born
for example pro-choicers are often
accused us of being merely pro birth and
pro lifers often lament that these
babies are never born
etc could you please offer some
clarification on these semantics I'm
curious to hear your thoughts because I
believe the language we use in regard to
this topic is incredibly important
especially when our offspring are so
tiny that people seem to have no trouble
convincing themselves that they do not
exist well no I don't think we can say
that they're born
I think born implies that the child is
alive so I don't think born is true but
I agree that the language is important
and I agree that oftentimes pro-abortion
people will want to talk about these
babies like they never existed at all
right and that's one of the one of the
lies that the abortion clinic tells
pregnant pregnant mothers that well you
could just get rid of this pregnancy and
be a be a mother some other time in the
future it now's not a good time to be a
mother you don't have to be a mother now
you can be a mother in the future well
no because a woman who gets an abortion
well a woman who is pregnant is a mother
the moment you become pregnant you're a
mother so she's a mother now there's no
there's no put in that genie back in the
bottle and if she gets an abortion she's
not going to go back to being just a
childless woman she will now be them the
mother of a dead child so in that sense
you're right I think in a certain sense
there is a kind of birth that occurs
really upon conception where upon
conception you you have three lives that
are created you have the the life of the
child
but then you have the mother who kind of
turns in transforms now into a in you
have a from a woman into a mother so
then you have the the man who goes from
being a man to a father and that's a
that's a very real transformation that
happens upon conception in that moment
and if you get an abortion the the
terrible tragic fact is that no you're
you're not you you you KITT you're not
reversing the clock you're not undoing
anything you're now the the parents of a
dead child and that of course is not the
message that they're going to hear from
the abortion clinics all right this is
from James says hi Matt my wife and I
have three kids ages three two and three
months old we also have a dog the kids
love to go and walks around our
neighborhood but with the newborn it
requires one of us to push a stroller
and hold a toddler's hand while the
other holds the dog's leash with the
other hand and this would be very
dangerous and nearly impossible without
kid leashes ours are more like handcuffs
than leashes though one padded cuff goes
on the patient two pair at the patient
the parents wrists the other on the
child
separated by three feet of plastic
coated coiled steel wire we don't drag
our kids behind us on the leashes
they're more of a backup for when they
let go of your hand or try to make a run
for the street I've got some strange
looks with them but I think it gives my
toddlers a sense of independence and
adventure that they wouldn't have
otherwise if they were strapped into a
double stoller stroller love the show
yeah you know this is why we talked
about child leashes briefly on the show
yesterday and I don't use them myself
I admit that as a as a non parent I used
to be very judgmental of the of the
people who use child leashes but now
that I have kids I understand it makes
sense it's a practical thing and you're
right I mean if there's nothing wrong
with strapping a kid into a stroller and
carting them around then what's wrong
with you know having them tethered that
way I don't really see much of a
difference honestly let's see this is
from Grayson says I listen to your
episode recently on body-positive
and I think that one of the biggest
things wrong with the movement is that
they do not think all bodies should be
positive I'm a college kid who's in love
with fitness and I've said that I'm so
body positive I don't let myself get
unhealthy and overweight and I got
excoriated in the college class for body
shaming people need to understand that
health is a definite range and the vast
majority of people are sedentary and fat
harsh but true probably however true
body positivity is not accepting
gluttony and eating themselves to an
early grave but rather taking care of
yourself by eating well and exercising
regularly on another note the BMI
calculator is a very poor way to judge
body fatness in in athletes young adults
and the elderly because muscles are
denser than fat and someone like you who
has more muscle than average is seen as
overweight in the scale when in reality
you're perfectly healthy
I am a six foot male at about 180 pounds
and my BMI is still registered as
overweight that's because my body fat
percentage is about 11% which means I
carry lots of muscle mass with little
mat a fat mass thereby skewing the scale
well yeah and I of course I agree that
that that it's not body shaming to
encourage people to be healthy and to
eat healthy that of course is absurd I
do think it's also true and we need to
acknowledge that there are different
body types and there are some people who
just from birth are kind of destined to
struggle more with with with you know
their weight who are going to have a
much harder time getting into shape and
certainly you could have a much harder
time because of their body type their
body shape gonna have a harder time
looking like they're in shape and I also
recognize that for me like i i've always
had a very high metabolism and and so i
can't take credit for the fact that i'm
not if i had maybe a normal metabolism i
may very well be obese right now because
i don't have a very healthy diet and i
basically eat whatever I want
and so I can't you know I have to I have
to recognize that it's a little bit some
of us have advantages in that area that
are not they're just biological we
didn't we didn't we didn't do anything
to earn them it's just that's just how
it
and there are also people who you know
are gonna struggle all the more because
of maybe they're of injury and so
they're not able to exercise as much and
then also women once they start having
babies that is it's going to be an extra
challenge and so all of these things all
these things need to be acknowledged and
we can't expect everyone to be a
bodybuilder
I'm not a bodybuilder right we can't
expect that of everyone not everyone's
supposed to be a bodybuilder or or you
know a fitness guru or a runway model
all of that is true however you know we
could acknowledge that without
concluding that it's perfectly fine and
acceptable and beautiful and wonderful
to be morbidly obese
so as you point out there is a there's a
there's a spectrum there's a scale of
what is you know considered healthy and
normal and maybe it's a it's a wider
scale than people thought for a long
time but definitely morbid obesity is
not in you know is way on the unhealthy
end of that spectrum and so we should be
able to say that without being accused
of body shaming all right finally this
is from Heidi says hey Matt I have a
scenario for you and it's one that
really happened my sister-in-law's
sister is a social worker at a high
school she was working with a girl who
found out she was pregnant a few months
down the road this girl also found out
that she had brain cancer doctors told
her that she needed to undergo chemo and
radiation to kill the cancerous tumor
but in doing that it would also kill her
baby her parents who were very religious
decided not to give their daughter the
chemo their daughter eventually passed
away a few months down the road the baby
survived when I heard this story I
struggled with it I struggle with it
because I'm pro-life but I was trying to
put myself in the shoes of those parents
and I can't imagine denying my daughter
cancer treatment knowing that if she
didn't get it it would kill her I should
note that at the time when the daughter
would have had to start the treatment
she was too early in her pregnancy to
deliver I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this well that's a just a terrible
case across the board
but as I have really terrible case but
as I've said before you know these are
the sorts of cases that pro-abortion
people will often use to prove
supposedly that sometimes abortion is
medically necessary but that is not the
case these sorts of cases as horrible as
they are are irrelevant to the abortion
discussion because if a woman is
pregnant and finds out that she has an
aggressive form of cancer it needs to
get chemo
it would not be abortion for her to get
to get to chemotherapy even if it's
known that the baby is probably going to
die that is not abortion abortion is the
direct intentional purposeful killing of
the unborn child where you take an
action for the sake of killing the child
that's abortion now doing something to
save the mother that you know will will
probably have the effect unfortunately
tragically of killing the baby that is
not abortion that's the principle of
double effect and it's it could be a
perfectly ethical thing to do
where you are doing something you're
doing a good thing
with good intentions even though it may
have also a very terrible negative side
effect and again that that can be a
perfectly ethical action so it is not
the case that pro lifers say at least I
certainly wouldn't say that a woman who
has finds out she has cancer while she's
pregnant it is required to just die of
cancer and not get it treated I don't
think that at all and you know it's it's
impossible to know what you would do in
these situations until you're in them
but I can tell you personally if that
was my wife I would be urging her
strongly to get the chemo and if that
was my child that was my daughter
you better believe she's getting the
chemo does that mean that I'm not
pro-life does that mean that I'm denying
the the personhood of the child no not
at all this is just a very this really
is just a difficult choice you have to
make
in order to save somebody's life and it
does not involve denying the personhood
of the child at all it's a it's a
tragedy more in the fact that the child
may not survive the treatment so we the
way that people talk about abortion they
say oh it's a difficult choice you have
to make usually no it's not this is this
is with abortion you're directly killing
an innocent child and no that's not just
that's not a difficult choice that's
just the wrong choice this kind of
situation you're talking about here this
really is a difficult choice where
abortion has nothing to do with it
doesn't factor in so you know this is
kind of similar to these hypotheticals
that I've talked about before that you
know somebody will say well what if
you're in a building and it's on fire
and there's a there's a two-year-old
child there and but then there's also a
bunch of frozen embryos and you could
only save one I mean who are you gonna
save are you gonna save the the embryos
are you gonna save the child and of
course everybody would which would save
the two-year-old child right and so
that's supposed to prove that we don't
really consider those embryos to be
human but not that's not the case at all
you're just in a situation where you
have to make that kind of horrible
choice it's like if if it was my wife in
the in the burning building and some
other woman who's not my wife I would
save my wife in a heartbeat does that
mean I'm denying the personhood of the
other woman does that no does that mean
that I want her to die no does that mean
I'm killing the other woman no it just
means that I'm in a situation where I
can only save one and so I have to make
that choice and the fact that the other
one dies is not my fault that I didn't
kill them it's not me I didn't do it
it's it's not murder
right that's what abortion is murder so
we could go all day with these kind of
hypotheticals
you got you have two people hanging off
a cliff you've got your child and
someone else's child
you can only save one who are you gonna
say well you're gonna save your child
right so those are the hypotheticals
this is a more real-world situation and
look I can't judge I don't know the
situation I don't know the particulars
of it so I'm not gonna make any judgment
or anything like that I'm just saying
based on what you've told me if it were
me my daughter's getting the chemo for
sure
there and I wouldn't have to compromise
my pro-life beliefs at all in in in
making that choice all right
we'll leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed
I'm Michael Knowles host of the Michael
Knowles show after years and years of
vilifying million as socialist gadfly
Bernie Sanders prepares finally to
release his tax returns and guess what
he's a millionaire we will analyze why
socialists always seem so interested in
accumulating wealth check it out at
daily wire com